la mp association martiniquaise où la
promotion de l'industrie représente
aujourd'hui à un supérieur si si plus de
la moitié du sable du salon pour
représentants quand même un chiffre
d'affaires qui est non négligeable mais
surtout nous représentons aussi plus de
4000 emplois ce n'est pas en rien dans
la conjoncture économique actuelle nous
distribuons quand même 220 millions de
salaire de 120 millions d'euros de
salaire c'est tout à fait je dirais
intéressant pour notre pays la
martinique il le public disent on est
toujours intéressé par tout ce qui est
local tout ce qui est fabriqué
localement et je crois que le public
martiniquais a compris que
les produits de l'industrie locale sont
fait pour lui
nous cherchons effectivement à nous
adapter aux goûts du consommateur à ses
traditions culinaires
donc c'est un salon effectivement qui
peut paraître un petit peu moins étendus
que les salons précédents mais qui en
tout cas présentent des éléments très
importants de notre industrie